hi chase crawford how are you i'm good
drew thank you for having me this
morning
thank you for coming on the show i was
watching your interview with uh jimmy
fallon
and um i was so excited to talk about
football and chip and dale's and all
that i was like well they're talking
about
yeah b plan it was great so yeah all the
stories i wanted to talk to you about i
was like oh they that oh yeah that one
that yeah okay
so i um we did a little um
research and we found out that there are
fan pages about your eyebrows
really yeah oh it's better than my feet
i guess but
you know that's good my eyebrows are up
there how are your feet are they
are they groomed semi because guys never
clipped their toenails what's up with
them no
not at all barely what get get this is
men i want to buy all of you a a clipper
um
but um how do you feel about the fact
that there's fan pages with your
eyebrows
um that's weird and i don't know i guess
uh
well i guess the big eyebrows are in you
know i don't know
i grew up in the era of brook shields
and the big eyebrows were everything
um this i did not see you do anywhere
would you possibly indulge uh doing an
eyebrow dance with me
an eyebrow yes i mean how's that how's
that work we just
uh i've never done it before but i feel
like i want to start a movement
okay so this is hashtag eyebrow dance
uh and we're kicking it off with none
other than mr eyebrows mr
everything at chase crawford all right
so
i said let's pick three different types
of music
and uh we're gonna kick it off with jazz
i've never done this either
[Music]
the next cue
[Music]
okay thank you thank you thank you
i i have no idea how that felt
for you or that was kind of weird but it
was really fun
and you're just fun and playful by the
way i know your like
suit is getting a lot of attention too
on the boys
oh it's got a little bit of a tension
yeah yeah it's uh
it's tight you know it's like a big
wetsuit onesie
um yeah there it is the gloves too with
the webbed fingers you know it's uh it's
a nice touch
i i think your role um all sort of
you know gentlemen and gossip girl and
everything aside and eyebrow fan pages
and hot
wet suits you're playing a really
interesting
character in the boys and i just think
the whole tone of it is so interesting
i'm a tone
freak and i thought the boys have such
an interesting tone and i know your
character deals with a lot of taboos
and it's really exciting to watch you
attack this
thank you thank you yeah i know but
first season we're kind of like i'm like
is this
like totally gonna work like you know
going from a a pretty
darkly darkly comedic scene to me you
know getting it
breaking a dolphin out of ocean land or
whatever but uh those tonal shifts
worked and um
it's a lot of fun it's a lot of fun for
me to do something totally different and
uh you know kind of play this dark
interesting you know defective
character so well i think this uh
little interview we've done has a lot of
weird tones in it too
and i hope that's okay for you because i
really had fun and by the way i love the
cowboys and i know your brother-in-law
is a cowboy tony romo and
i mean that just must be so much fun go
dallas
i know go dallas you grew up there or
you grew up in lubbock
i was born in lubbock i grew up there
for like a couple years then in dallas
mainly my whole life so yeah i've been
out there my family's still there got
three little nephews and uh yeah
well i have to say i think i'm a sky
lover i'm in a california hippie big
surprise
i love the sky and there's no other
skies in the world on planet earth like
in texas
no other skies good thunderstorms it's
nice down there
thank you chase for gracing us with your
presence you are so awesome so playful
the boys is available on amazon prime
[Music]
you